I'm going to end it if it doesn't end
Kevin Costner is staying on the Dutton
Ranch for now you should think twice how
far plenty about it yeah Costner's done
some thinking and he's speaking out
through his attorney Marty singer who's
slamming a report that Costner wants to
spend Just One Week shooting season
five's remaining episodes scheduled to
air this Summer singer calls the rumor
in absolute lie quote anyone suggesting
it shouldn't be believed for one second
my guess is that the version of
Yellowstone that we know is probably
going to end with this season I think
the negativity right now has gotten to a
point where it's going to be very
difficult for him to come back to the
show this comes after reports first
surfaced a few weeks ago hinting that a
storm was brewing at Dutton Ranch in
real life but a spokesperson for
Yellowstone's Network Paramount told E.T
there's no news to report and added
Kevin Costner is a big part of
Yellowstone and we hope that's the case
for a long time to come I can tell you
there'll be six
and there'll be a seven that's all I can
tell you meanwhile et's learned
production hasn't started because the
last half of season five is still being
written Kevin Costner is famously
headstrong and he has been at odds with
Taylor Sheridan the creator of the show
for months now over the dates that he's
going to be shooting for the next part
of the season
is the one constant in life
you build something worth having
someone's going to try and take it like
Matthew McConaughey
how about you lay that shield on this
table Yeah another rumor McConaughey is
saddling up for a new role in Kevin's
absence Paramount said at the time
Matthew McConaughey is a phenomenal
Talent with whom we'd love to partner if
I had to bet I would say that he's
probably going to leave and that the
show will end and they will do a new
version of Yellowstone starring Matthew
McConaughey where maybe some of the
characters from Yellowstone go on to
that new show maybe they ended entirely
behind Costner's possible early exit
directing from last August to November
he's been at the helm of his own Civil
War epic Horizon
I have other things that I will
want to do directing producing and
starring in it that's awesome
it's a bunch that being said his
attorney added on Thursday Kevin is
incredibly passionate about Yellowstone
and has always gone above and beyond to
ensure its success
that success has been good to Costner he
makes a reported 1.3 million dollars per
episode ask your husband where the train
station is and how many times he's been
there the series last left off teasing a
Dutton versus Dutton Showdown
he will use everything that he knows to
destroy you
he has made it clear
yes I believe he has I'll go tell I'm
not interested I'm going to end it if it
doesn't end
[Music]